I think one of the key elements of
successfully retaining and motivating
people throughout the organization is
communication really good communication
I think it needs to be frequent and I
think it needs to be honest and
straightforward and as informative as
you can possibly be I found when in the
past when I've put together strategic
plans for a company that that's an
essential element because you can start
at the top and you can sit around a
board room and you can come up this
great strategy and have great people at
the top of the organization that all get
it all by the strategy etc but you've
got to get it down through the through
the organization and you have to get
people to buy into it all through the
organization not just the senior people
in the company but you've got to have
your your regional people and your
district people in your general managers
in your stores and even even the people
that are out on the sales floor or
interacting with customers they all have
to sort of be marching in the same
direction and I think the communication
is vitally important that we put a lot
of emphasis on frequent communication
certainly headquarters will do you know
a lot of certainly written communication
but we also have regular town hall
meetings and we try to really open
ourselves up for questions and really be
able to answer those questions is
honestly and frankly as possible
whatever is on our people's mind if it's
something because we're a public company
we can't answer then we just say we
can't answer that because I don't want
to go to jail just as simple as that you
aren't able to do it on the other hand
aside from that unless it's something
that's just vitally confidential going
on within the company that can be
happening right now we're in us and
we're waiting different strategic
alternatives for the company some things
you can talk about some you can't but
again it goes back to what you can even
legally do but aside from that I tell
them anything for a game they can ask
questions an example of being open to
questions within the company which i
think is so important for motivating
people retaining them etc recently we
announced that we were seeking strategic
alternatives for our company which could
include the possible sale of either
parts or even all of our company well
immediately we did that we're legally
required to do that by sec rules etc
immediately when you do it
you have 35,000 people out there that
are all starting to get real nervous
what does it mean for me what does it
mean for the future etc and particularly
people at headquarters because if you
look at a lot of scenarios that would be
out there or if I almost any scenario
out there that the borders would be sold
the stores you know would be in pretty
good shape you know we have we have a
lot of great stores out there and the
stores will still be needed headquarters
however there could be possible
scenarios I mean with the certain
strategic buyer or whatever that that
could possibly eliminate the
headquarters in Ann Arbor that we have
there too so that that's the way heavily
on people's minds so but we felt like we
had to really you know be
straightforward with people and say yes
is it a possibility it's possibility but
there are any number of other
possibilities as well and you try to
keep people informed as you go through
the process and he's try to be up front
one of the things that came out of those
initial meetings when we had those and
announced the strategic alternatives was
that people immediately said well what's
that going to mean you also mentioned in
part of this process that you were going
to be lowering overhead and cost what is
what does that mean does that mean we're
going to have John eliminations we have
layoffs in the company and my answer
that was back in at the end of March my
answer was yes it does because we knew
that it was going to be necessary for us
to have job eliminations in the process
and if we had not been straightforward
and answered that truthfully even though
it put some unrest within headquarters
people for a couple of months to we
completed the process recently you had
to answer it truthfully because
otherwise when you come back later and
people say well gee are there's a rumor
out there that we may be going bankrupt
whatever to and you hear start hearing
stuff like that which is completely
ridiculous you know but to be able to
say that to people and have them believe
it you've had to be truthful with them
previously I've just found in turn
arounds especially it's just vitally
vitally important to do that to be able
to communicate frequently with people to
answer the questions as frankly as you
possibly can and and and and to build
credibility and Trust by doing that and
by being credible with them on front end
when we had the recent job eliminations
I was also then I was able to go the
people and say that's it we've taken the
cuts necessary we have no
eliminations plan you know for our
corporate headquarters so now you can
breathe easily and let's get back and we
and roop together and refocus on on
delivering iron our nation's and
delivering on our strategic plan and
people